I don't think that the state of New
Jersey should be able to keep my son's
blood I did not consent to it I did not
agree to it there was no explanation in
the hospital and I do not think that's
right at all New Jersey steals baby's
blood and keeps it for years yeah it's
as weird as it
sounds all states test newborn's blood
for genetic disorders but instead of
throwing away the blood New Jersey keeps
it for 23 years and they don't tell
parents what is the government doing
with the baby blood whatever they want
with no oversight New Jersey officials
have handed over blood to law
enforcement without a warrant and even
sold it to third parties and New Jersey
isn't the first state to do this Texas
used to turn over infant blood samples
to the Pentagon in hopes of creating a
National Registry a group of parents
filed a lawsuit over New Jersey's blood
retention scheme but they shouldn't have
to genetic testing of newborns doesn't
Grant the government a free pass to sell
or store DNA without someone's consent